je m'appelle aline dia alias webster
pourra mettre dans le temps pour
quelques instants jeune artiste époque
avec les conférences des visites guidées
le livre le grand sable le rappeur
historiens de québec
webster a conçu et organisé une
exposition au musée national des
beaux-arts de québec et pour faire
découvrir l'histoire méconnue des
esclaves en nouvelle france et pendant
le régime anglais l'objectif de cette
exposition là c'est de mettre de l'avant
cette identité satire met de l'avant ces
hommes ces femmes ces enfants qui
étaient considérés comme des esclaves
mais qu'on ne peut pas enfermer
historiquement dans ce statut d'esclave
autre chose que des esclaves
il a fouillé dans les journaux de
l'époque et découvert des perles dans
les petites annonces dont j'ai à vendre
une jeunesse un [ __ ] une barrique mais
lâche donc sont des gens qui sont
considérés comme des objets comme des
biens meubles certains esclaves en fuite
étaient identifiés et soigneusement
décrit dans des avis de recherches
publiées par leurs maîtres
webster a choisi de mettre l'accent sur
une dizaine d'entre eux jo pour moi
c'est vraiment la figure de cette
exposition là parce que jo ce souffle de
temps et je pense admettons abel qui
s'est enfui nu-pieds bête qui s'est
enfui enceinte donc des gens qui
finalement ont dû avoir du courage
[Musique]
je pense entre autres animaux et cache
cache qui s'est sauvé plusieurs
vêtements et s'est annoncée dans
l'annonçons dit elle va probablement
changer son habillement je pense à andré
qui lui se sauveront l'annoncent
comédien est faux certificats de sa
franchise et faux passeport
donc lui a fait ou s'est fait faire des
documents pour faire ce faire paraître
comme étant une personne libre
le premier esclaves connu et ressentir
aux nouvelles forces est un certain
olivier lejeune capturé à madagascar et
emmenée par des anglais au début du
xviie siècle tel que le raconte webster
dans son livre illustré par son ami
valmont dès l'arrivée européenne ici
avant
ans moi aussi et toc si le travail que
j'essaie de faire enfin fait c'est de
remettre la lumière sur ces pages
méconnues et donner un portrait qui ma
foi est plus juste de notre histoire
l' esclavage a commencé de manière
informelle la nouvelle france en 16 129
des amérindiens aux frais parfois aux
colons français des ennemis autochtones
capturer qu'ils avaient a servi après la
conquête britannique
la pratique s'est élargie avec l'arrivée
d'esclaves noirs provenant des antilles
et des colonies américaines
en tout près de 4200 esclaves ont été
recensés ici
deux tiers d'entre eux étaient
autochtone les autres afrodescendants
en attendant jacques rault d'eau qui a
émis une ordonnance pour dire que si
vous achetez d un noir ou un indien il
vous appartient en pleine propriété
c'est ça qui a légalisé l'esclave âge en
nouvelle france
c'est arrivé
marie-angélique esclaves noirs accusés
probablement à tort d'avoir incendié
montréal et pendu en 1734 sous la
torture
j'ai dit que c'était moi aujourd'hui sa
mémoire est évoquée dans divers
spectacles présentés dans le vieux
montréal la ville et le gouvernement du
québec lui ont rendu hommage en nommant
un parc à son nom
c'est pas rare pour les noirs c'est que
c'est un bouc émissaire
c'est une femme elle avait de la gueule
est un peu maussade basse était la
candidate idéale 4 le feu à prix bas à
7,1 à partir de 1802 l'esclavagé
disparaît progressivement les autorités
cessent de poursuivre les esclaves en
fuite
c'est à partir de ce moment alors
qu'elles lisent les escarres et les
esclavagistes les maîtres d'esclaves ont
compris que si ça dure est-ce ça voulait
dire qu'on pouvait plus avoir de ce
clivage les maîtres avait aucun contrôle
sur leurs esclaves si les esclaves
vérité n'importe quand
même si ces esclaves ne sont pas mes
ancêtres
à moi de tout même une filiation de
cette universalité noir
là c'est la race d'une construction
sociale c'est pas une réalité biologique
et cette construction la sociale un
impact sur nos vies et c'est la raison
pour laquelle une histoire qui
m'intéresse pas la mémoire de
l'esclavagé au canada s'est diluée avec
le temps et les métissages ce qui
explique peut-être que des gens comme
webster aux origines africaines métis et
insiste pour faire revivre ce pan
d'histoire commodément oublié